the Joe Rogan experience one thing that
always trips me out is I think about
like people with you as lunatics I'm
like what if they are seeing reality and
we have blinders on you know because
when you take into account what a finite
percentage of what's really out there
that we're able to see without
perception you know compared to like
x-rays and gamma-rays and all of these
things like we have such a tiny filter
on everything that's really going on out
there yeah we don't really see we don't
see [ __ ] compared to what's really there
and like maybe these whacked-out people
are just seeing more of what's happening
and that's what makes them nuts because
they're like not seeing all these demons
flying around and all these colors and
like we just have we have a filter on
that so we can like process information
but like it and it keeps us sane but
that's I mean what's really going on out
there
well you think about how small amount of
acid you need to take to completely
perturb the way you view the world yeah
you know I think McKenna described this
turns McKenna described acid that the
potency of acid is like it's literally
like full in terms of like the amount
that you need in order to have an effect
he made an analogy like an ant
deconstructing the entire Empire State
Building in a matter of seconds mm-hm
like that's how potent it is in terms of
volume you don't need a couple drops of
acid in a huge human body and you're
tripping balls for seven hours yeah you
know that's a chemical disruption of
this very delicate ecosystem mm-hmm so
if your neuro chemistry is off in any
way up or down sideways screwy you got
too much of this or too much of that
yeah which we know is the case with
everything right like some people are
born with bad eyesight some people are
born deaf some people are born and they
have problems processing pain they don't
feel pain correctly some people are born
and they must have an imbalance of the
chemicals that are floating around
inside your head yeah and their view of
the world is radically different than
ours yeah
and also those chemicals can shift
depending on for your personal
experience like life abuse children that
are abused their chemicals in their head
as they're developing or off they're
different their brains are different
they process life different because of
abuse people that have experienced
extremes trauma extreme violence when
they're young PTSD they're processing
things differently the people that
have-not yeah what's even crazier about
that is I read a book called it didn't
start with you and it talks about how
these things are passed on
generationally from like trauma your
grandparents had is passed on to you
through your DNA and it and it and it
changes us like how much is passed on to
us that we have no control over and then
alters our the way we feel things we see
things all of these experiences that
people have that just get passed passed
down like that without any outside
influence just just through that process
of being do you have any children no
when you have children you see it in a
really weird way look my middle daughter
my 11 year old is an obsessive yeah like
she's obsesses on things and tries to
get better on them or you got to try to
tell her hey time to go to bed she's
doing like backflips in a Roman shed
like stop stop go to bed like you got to
go to bed but that's me
like and I always thought it was [ __ ]
up I was like I thought I was doing this
and I probably was my whole life to try
to show that I had value because I felt
like I was ignored and I didn't know my
dad and I was felt like an outsider and
a loser
and I always felt like I would become I
would throw myself into things to show
that I had value and I would get really
good at things to show that I had value
and that would be this obsession was
like me trying like trying to escape the
existential angst of my existence and
just the the constant anxiety and this
just feeling of just inadequacy trying
to escape it by being obsessed with
things but also trying to prove through
getting good at things that I have value
because the first time I ever felt like
was worth anything was when I started
getting good at martial arts like and
then people started respecting me I was
like oh I have a thing that people think
I'm good at know that I'm good at this
thing that became my identity and then
but just threw myself into that but my
daughter's growing up with none of that
like she's all loved and she's all
smiling and happy and she's not
depressed
she it's a lot of hugs and she has
friends but she's a [ __ ] psycho
and I'm like oh you got that for me like
you got my crazy gene but you got it
without all the [ __ ] up parts right
like you're not sad you got it without
the sad thing you just want to get good
at stuff without like a happiness to it
and also a feminine happiness to it
instead of a masculine like a girl just
wanted to smash yeah that's all I wanted
to do I just want to smash things
because I was angry she's not angry so
it's weird to see this obsessive like
completely obsessive behavior in terms
of like trying to get better at things
and she accelerates it she excels at so
many different things that she gets good
at yeah she gets good at things and they
become her whole life like all day long
obsessive like it's really weird but in
a happy way and it's so it's it's
strange genetically yeah you know and
you know you've met my dog Marshall the
[ __ ] nicest dog in the world
right he's so nice no that's a genetic
thing that dog is a golden retriever and
when he like when you come over to him
and he starts whining is so happy and he
wants to get pat and he runs and grabs a
toy always he always wants to bring you
something like I didn't teach him that
yeah I've had him for three years I've
had him since he was a little tiny baby
who's like six weeks old when I got him
never had a rough day in his life
every day's been fun but he's learned
through his DNA that he's supposed to
retrieve things and bring them over and
that you are happier when he brings
things over because that's the DNA
that's in his system it's not he didn't
learn it yeah this is literally inside
of him from the box like right out of
the box look at the ingredients oh he
likes to bring you things yeah because
his ancestors brought you things his
ancestors brought other people things
and they were rewarded for and they said
oh they give me treats and they like me
more when I bring things so I'm going to
just cute when you know you shoot a duck
out of the sky and they can't get that
duck and bring it over and everybody
gets happy so that's in him yeah it's
crazy I don't think we understand what
what DNA actually is or whatever the
[ __ ] you dude DNA is just a name right
whether the components of the life-form
that are passed when two life-forms
breed and they make another one I don't
think we really understand it I think we
we have a rudimentary understanding of
the chemistry involved but in terms of
like personality and in terms of like
the the thoughts that are in our heads
like I was reading something by Rupert
Sheldrake and he was talking about why
children are afraid of monsters he's
like children that grow up in the city
or afraid of monsters they're not afraid
of like gunshots and car accidents
things that are really scary they're
afraid of monsters because our ancient
ancestors were eaten by cats yeah they
were eaten and by wolves and those kind
of things so we're afraid of fangs and
things in the dark when you can't see
them coming you can't protect yourself
yeah
crazy crazy it's in there it's in the
DNA yeah I mean there's so much of
there's so much stuff like that that
just we don't understand anything
have you ever met someone that has like
a legit phobia like a video phobia or
arachnophobia like fear of snakes or
spiders I know that I have I'm trying to
think of who that was but yeah it's like
where did that come from its DNA man I
guarantee you I've seen it on fear
factor we had a few people that had a
legit fear of snakes and spiders they're
like oh my god oh my god you see that
whole body was shaking and they were
trying like hey this aren't even [ __ ]
poisonous yeah these are just snakes but
there's something about snakes like
someone they love or there is someone in
their ancestry or some someone survived
a snake attack something
[Applause]